>> Laura: WELL, IT'S FRIDAY, AND
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
TONIGHT'S THEME -- INTERRUPTING
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
JOINING US NOW WITH ALL THE
DETAILS, RAYMOND ARROYO,
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR OF THE
BRAND-NEW BOOK.
THERE WERE A FEW HIGH-PROFILE
EXAMPLES OF REPORTERS GETTING
MORE THAN THEY BARGAINED FOR IN
THE FIELD.
>> AT THE CANADIAN BROADCASTING
CORPORATION, A REPORTER WAS LIVE
AT A COMEDY CLUB WHEN ACTOR BOYD
BANKS APPROACHED.
WATCH.
>> THEY'RE HOPING THIS TOWN HALL
WILL STOP THIS TRANSITION, BUT
THINGS ARE GETTING A LITTLE
AWKWARD OUT HERE, SO I'M GOING
TO PASS IT BACK TO YOU.
>> WHAT A JERK.
HE NIBBLED ON HIS EAR.
HE NOW HAS COME OUT WITH A
STATEMENT.
>> Laura: CAN'T YOU IMMEDIATELY
DEFEND YOURSELF.
>> I WOULD THINK YOU CAN POP
THIS GUY IN THE MOUTH.
HE SAID HE NEEDS TREATMENT FOR
HIS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THIS HAPPENS FOR MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN PEOPLE ARE AWARE.
HE CLAIM THAT IS HE'S GUILTY FOR
EVERYTHING AND, LIKE SMOLLETT,
HE HAS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THAT'S THE CONVENIENT GO-TO.
>> Laura: BASIC MANNERS ISSUES.
>> SOME PICKED UP THINGS THEY
NEVER INTEND.
HE WAS POSTED OUTSIDE THE COHEN
HEARING ROOM AND AN UNAWARE
YOUNG MAN DIDN'T KNOW HE WAS
LIVE ON TV.
>> ACTUALLY WINNING THE JOB.
AND YOU CAN SIT THERE AND SAY,
YEAH, BUT THIS IS AN UNCREDIBLE
WITNESS BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN
SAYING ONE THING JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> Laura: I CAN HEAR A FRIEND OF
MINE SAYING, AMERICANS EAT IN
PUBLIC LIKE THIS.
>> AWFUL, AWFUL.
BUT, LAURA, SADLY, TOO MANY
PEOPLE THINK THAT REPORTERS ARE
PLAYTHINGS.
THEY SEE THEM ON TV.
SO THEY EITHER RELAX AROUND THEM
OR THINK THEY CAN DO THESE SILLY
THINGS.
MY HERO WHEN IT COMES TO HAZING
IN THE FIELD AND DEALING WITH
THIS IS OUR OWN MIKE TOBIN.
>> TEN SECONDS LATER, THE SECOND
EXPLOSION GOES OFF.
PLEASE DON'T DO THAT.
WHERE HE DROPPED HIS KNAPSACK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I LOVE THE DOUBLE HAND.
PLEASE DON'T DO THAT, WITHOUT
MISSING A BEAT.
>> Laura: HE'S STRONG.
IF ANYONE COMES UP YOU AND
TOUCHES YOU, YOU CAN DO A QUICK
ELBOW.
>> ONCE THEY TOUCH YOU.
>> Laura: NO, NO, NO.
>> JENNIFER LAWRENCE STARS IN A
NEW FILM CALLED "UNBREAKING
AMERICA."
IT IS A CELEBRITY PSA THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO ACQUAINT THE
AUDIENCE WITH THE CORRUPTION IN
THE GOVERNMENT AND WHAT CAN WE
DO ABOUT IT.
>> HOW DO WE UNRIG THIS SYSTEM?
I'M OBSESSED WITH THIS IDEA.
NEARLY HALF OF AMERICAN VOTERS
ARE REGISTERED AS INDEPENDENTS.
BUT IT ALL ADDS UP TO THIS VAST
RING OF INFLUENCE OVER OUR
ELECTED LEADERS.
IT'S A CORRUPT SYSTEM IN WHICH
WE THE PEOPLE HAVE NEAR ZERO
INFLUENCE OVER OUR GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS SAD.
THAT IS NOT THE COUNTRY I FEEL
LIKE I GREW UP IN.
>> WHAT COUNTRY DO YOU THINK YOU
GREW UP?
>> Laura: SHE'S ONLY 28 YEARS
OLD.
WATERGATE WAS IN THE '70S.
>> SHE'S ADVOCATING AN
ANTI-CORRUPTION BILL.
THEY WANT AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION AND AT-HOME VOTING.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO OVERTHROW
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THE CORRUPTION ACT IS ACTUALLY
IN ITSELF A CORRUPTION.
>> Laura: SHE SAID THERE'S A